hello very nice to meet you hope you're
doing well I jump into it here this is
your very first acting role so did
anyone out there give you any tips or
advice for jumping into this um no I
kind of just I kind of just jumped in I
think I didn't want to think too hard
about it or overthink I just kind of
went into it and thankfully everybody on
the team from the Willoughby's was there
and Kris Pearn he was like the the guy
behind all this was was there guiding me
so it was good it was helpful to have
him there for sure
would you say is the most surprising
thing about the voice-acting process is
there anything that made you think like
I can't believe that's how they do that
yeah a bunch of different things I mean
first of all how long it takes I didn't
know that it took I mean my case three
years to film just a two hour movie
which is crazy
because it's constantly evolving and
changing but also I mean there's like
little things like when like Jane had to
eat I was like literally eating like
sandwiches and like the more noise the
better so you're just kind of like
slobbering on a mic to get like the
perfect sound which is kind of funny but
like a bunch of little things like that
or how many times get to say a line like
you'll say one line and you have to say
like but I love that process I think
it's fun so it took you three years to
record what you needed for this what
were you recording at the beginning of
that process compared to the end is it
just you know filling in little things
here or there by the end or is it
something that goes with adjusting their
animation um
act I mean it depends at times I was I
mean like the end of the process they
already had some animation done so at
that point I was kind of recording to
picture and sort of like filling in what
she was doing and then in the beginning
obviously there wasn't any animation
animation so it was just sort of me
shaping the character shaping her voice
I think her age changed I think she
started out as like seven and now she's
12 so my voice even just my own voice in
three years kind of changed so it's sort
of revolved and then by the end I was
fine tuning and tweaking her her lines
to fit what she is now what was it like
working
with Chris on her personality
transformation throughout the movie
because one of my absolute favorite
parts is when she first meets Maddie and
even things that aren't necessarily part
of the voice performance but just when
you see her pick up nanny's mannerisms
in the background is that's something
that you guys just have to talk through
or was there any opportunity to maybe
work with Maya and see what she was
doing and then kind of absorbed that
into Jane a little as much as I would
have loved to work with her because I
loved her we didn't get to work together
but thankfully it was that scene was
later on in the process where she had
already done her parts and it was there
was some animation there so I got to see
what it looked like and so I was
recording to picture and hearing her
voice in my headphones it was so helpful
because I got to like play off of her
energy is so so much better I think it
really is such a touching part of the
film so obviously you have tons of
experience singing but was there
anything voiced technique-wise for
voicing an animated character that you
found surprisingly challenging yeah I
mean it's hard to amount certain things
when you can't see no you have to just
do it with your voice so little things
like if she was a little bit sad or she
was a questioning or a little skeptical
like you kind of really have to to play
in on like the different areas that your
your voice goes to I guess if that makes
sense so it was hard to emot-- certain
things just with my voice because I mean
when you're singing there's like a
couple of emotions that I you know that
I can convey but usually it's like your
standard happy sad whatever but like
this is like very nuanced it's very
challenging to like make that perfect so
would you say that you've been bit by
the acting bug now would you want to
maybe move on to a live-action role next
I don't know I'm still very camera shy
but at the same time I loved like drama
and theatre growing up I was always in
in theatre so we'll see I don't know I
do enjoy it but I have to like get more
comfortable I think let's say someone
else out there is about to jump into
their very first voice acting role after
having this experience what one major
tip would you give them to help them get
through it um I would say don't be shy
just like if you want to scream a lot
to scream it just don't be afraid of
sounding dumb or looking dumb like who
cares just go for it cuz at the end of
the day it's what the character needs
you know it's not even about you do you
remember the part in this process that
first made you do that did you have kind
of a breakthrough moment where you
finally I don't know kind of just went
for and acted silly and then you felt
good about it going forward yeah
definitely there are so many times where
Christians like just ad-lib apart here
just say what you feel and he would just
kind of hand off the floor to me and I
just remember like making up stuff and
just like screaming and just doing
different things and that was really
helpful just to get stuff out cuz you
really just remember that it's not you
it's you're lending your voice of
someone else and the second you like
stop worrying about it like looking down
then it you give so much more well job
well done I'm glad you learned able to
jump into it and get silly because this
movie is colorful vibrant and it's just
wacky in the best sense so
congratulations thank you thank you so
much